hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the world blitz championship
we are in the final day of the
championship and it is around 18 it's a
madness Crossland versus a former world
champion Vladimir Kramnik and after his
win against Daniel dubov across and drew
against young shoots of Duda and now he
faces flood Mitt Romney who retired from
professional chess but he came out of
retirement to enjoy this short blitz
tournament he didn't participate in the
rapid but still there are only well few
people that can tackle him in Boots as
he is doing extremely well in this
tournament facing call across and so
late in the tournament and also he's
been practicing with
alpha0 now with the deep mines team you
know checking out all that no castling
gross stuff so who knows what dirty
secrets he uncovered as of late that
being said let's check out the game
Magnus with the white pieces again goes
for his London system we have Knight to
f6 Knight f3 d5 and Bishop to f4 the
london system is on the board we have a
c5 by Kramnik ending our e3 and this is
a well it's it's a great example because
the London system or usually doesn't
really pose any problems for black if
black is able to counter it properly and
who better to test it out then against
Vladimir Kramnik with night that's
another night
nice to see six night BT 2 by Magnus and
seek actress on d4 E cap trois on d4 and
now Queen to b6 attacking d4 and b2 so
Knight B 3 covers both of those threats
preparing a4 a5 something the cost and
always goes for Bishop to f5 and then
out Bishop to e2 it this is a new move
in the position so as of mu8 we have a
completely new game we have e 6 by
Kramnik preparing to develop the dark
square Bishop Magnus castles and Bishop
to e7 we have a for preparing to pull
the Queen further with a5 a6 by cramming
and now a5 we have Queen back to d8 a7
is possible but with the bishop covering
b8 it would be you would have to wait to
push b5 to get the Queen away from there
so Queen to d8
and Knight to e5 now an excellent square
for the knight we have looked the c8 by
kramnik and now c3 just
strengthen in the center castles by
Kramnik and now rook to e1 with Knight
to e4 also an excellent square for
economics Knight and Bishop to d3 now if
the knight moves you can capture on f5
and double black spawns so Romney goes
Knight captures on e5 Bishop characters
and now brush up to g6 so the trade
happens on g6 instead of an f5 the
shabak the f4 magnus doesn't want to
allow f6 and d5 to come with the attempt
MP and the bishop so Knight back to d6
now kramnik offers a trade of lights
worships Magnus captures with Bishop
captures pawn captures and now this is
one of those decisions that magnus
carlsen can make in an instant and well
for everyone else we would probably
decide on what the best move here but
Magnus goes for Bishop captures and e6
something that well not a lot of people
would play as you give up your bishop
and you go into this night versus a
district game where if you trade down
into an endgame most likely you will not
be able to hold Vladimir Kramnik but
Carlsen does not intend to go for the
endgame here here Carlsen plans to
attack and he starts with the g3 point
is he wants to play h4 h5 open up the H
file play king g2 and bring the rook
over to the open H file and then use the
Queen perhaps checkmate the black King
so let's see how that goes we have b5 by
kramnik Kramnik of course wants to play
on the Queen side a capture Sun b6 Queen
captures and the now rookie to assault
the knight can move the b2 point is now
protected rook to b8 challenging the
night and not Knight back to c1 the
knight is now coming to d3 from where
the knight will also control the B to
pawn a five by chronic chronic wants to
push a 4 and a 3 and if he can break up
this structure here then his position
will be excellent
we have Knight 2 D 3 by Magnus and Queen
tab b5 now preparing to further expand
with a four and now Carlsen starts with
h4 now with rook F to c8 and now rook to
d2 now the Queen can move as the knight
is also guarded by the rook rook to e8
now preparing to push the pawn to a4 and
a3 and here h5 by Magnus Kramnik doesn't
want to allow H captures the weaken the
the pawn chain so the
chapters on h5 himself Queen captures on
h5 and now g6 now we have Queen to h6
and now a fork Romney continues to play
on the Queen side whereas Crossin plays
on the Kings side we have King g2 and
it's a really safe square for the King
as the the d5 pawn is on a light square
so kramnik is unable to move it to use
this diagonal for attack and the dark
square bishop will not be very useful
here so you cannot allow rook to h1 to
count while your queen is on h6 this is
just instant maid
so our kramnik kicks it away Bishop to
f6 and now Queen to f4 now Magnus is
preparing a 95 to go after the f7 pawn
goes from g7 but Knight to e5 still you
cannot capture it if you capture it
Queen captures then there's just no
stopping rock H 1 to H 8 it's completely
lost so the dark square bishop is an
essential part of kremlings defences so
you have to guard the f7 point in Bator
by rho k 7 or queen te 8 kramnik prefers
queen 38 she wants to keep the rook here
as an option to push a three now we have
looked a d3 by Magnus now trying to get
another attacker to the f7 pawn with f6
cremini has to play something to push it
away and night the g4 now with a double
attack on the f6 pawn queen to f8 and
now rook to f3 and here kramnik was
already much lower untimed and then
Magnus and in a three minute
blitz game that is a lot to take into
account so a three by Kramnik there's no
point in trying to defend the f6 pawn
Magnus just captures it and now you
cannot recapture if you capture it's
winning for Magnus captures captures
captures and now you can just capture on
f6 with check there's nothing to do here
you can just capture characters the
thread is just capture some g6 and if
you go back that doesn't really do
anything just captures Queen g7 captures
here you win the rook and that's just
game
so first f5 by chronic and now a
beautiful move by Magnus Queen to g5 now
not allowing captures because of
captures so King to f7 that Kramnik
tries to run away with the King now but
rook to h1 Magnus now abandons the
defense of the a3 pawn because the rook
to h7 is just too great
still how many characters you have to
play something with rooked
h7 in here Kramnik captures the other
pawn as well so here feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
move for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
because every move wins here and for
those who just want to enjoy a show if
you found a rook captures and c3 that's
enough for a win if you found Queen to
f6 check that's enough for a win since
the bishop is pinned but Magnus played
the quickest way to victory nights the
h6 check
you cannot capture as the the bishop is
pinned
so King te it was played and now Queen
characters and g6 with check here gromek
played King to d8 but it was also in
this position that he resigned because
like we said every every move wins here
just you can capture on c3 for example
real characters now you pick up the the
bishop here you can just win the Queen
you can try and checkmate
the black king right away so everything
wins here but it's just amazing this
moment where well I forgot where the
moment was but after all the trades I
think it was around here let me just go
back for a few seconds yeah it was
fairly early on in the game this moment
is so it's only move 18 how quickly
Magnus decided to go for this captures
and captures and how well he knows the
London system so London system isn't
dangerous in itself it's what you do
with it that matters so this is one such
example where you can just use these
pawns on light squares as a shield to
play g3 tandem of the the dark square
Bishop lay King G to open up the H file
really just a very instructive game so
now once again I do hope you enjoyed
that cost instill in so lead after
beating Vladimir Kramnik
who was who was trailing behind him so
we'll see what happens I would like to
thank Hugh quite run and Gleb cope chunk
of a Joseph mottier
how many mizuchi and TAS was arm passes
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video Sarah thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the world blitz championship
until it ends so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day